[APPLAUSE]
JERRY: Hi, everybody.
How are you?
BRIAN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Brian.
JERRY: I'm Jerry Harvey.
BRIAN: This is Jerry.
JERRY: Nice to meet you.
BRIAN: So, I figured that we'd
talk, just a Q & A with me
and Jerry for a bit,
but feel free to jump in
with questions anytime you want.
And we'll talk for maybe
about a half hour or so,
and then we can do some
questions at the end.
You can talk
about-- ask anything
you want about Ultimate
Ears, about JH audio,
about audio technology,
anything like that.
So we'll cover it all,
from the beginning to now.
JERRY: Yup.
Ready to go.
BRIAN: That cool?
Are you ready?
JERRY: Yeah.
And also make sure everyone
gets a raffle ticket.
We're giving away a set
of Roxannes, so make sure
you get your ticket in
there for that, at the end.
BRIAN: Yeah, and afterwards,
also, for the whole day,
we'll be demoing--
or Dr. Glick, who's
in the back there-- will be
demoing all the models of JH,
so you can listen to them,
and they all sound amazing,
even if you're not a rock star.
So, please enjoy.
So I thought we'd
start by just talking
about how this story begins.
So you're a guy who
wasn't a musician,
and had no connections
to this business,
and somehow got wrapped
up with a bunch of guys
from Van Halen, and Sammy Hagar,
and sort of got you, sort of,
mixed into this business.
And maybe just talk
about how that started,
and how you went from a
guy who just likes music
to a guy who became
indispensable to these guys.
JERRY: Yeah, when I was a kid,
I met a guy named Roger Moore,
and he had a little local band.
I was teaching karate to
him, right, as a side thing,
so I could have my free lessons.
But anyway, he had
this band, and I
wanted to get into the
bar-- I was under age,
so I thought if I
could move gear in,
that I could get into the bar
without having to have an ID.
So that's kind of
how it started.
And then-- I had learned to
mix, kind of by trial and error.
I was really bad for
the first few years,
and people were not
shy to tell me that.
So anyway, I was mixing,
and I had a couple mentors,
and I started to get fairly--
get pretty good at it.
And I was driving down the
road, and it's kind of weird
that Van Halen just kind of
intertwined into my life,
just out of the blue.
I was driving down the
road, I had a red Trans Am,
it was, like, 1980, right?
And I get pulled
over, and this guy
was a promoter rep for
Contemporary Productions.
He says, hey, Sammy Hagar
is playing Busch Stadium
on Saturday, and we need him to
drive your car out on to stage,
because he's got a song
called "Trans Am," right?
So, I was, like,
all right, whatever.
I want to get into the show,
so I'll go down there, so--
BRIAN: Sounds legit.
JERRY: Yeah.
So, he showed me his card, so I
was, like, yeah, I'll show up.
So I showed up, they let
me in, and they go, well,
we're gonna introduce
you to Sammy Hagar.
I was, like, all right, great.
So I walk up, and I
go, hi, I'm Jerry,
he goes, hi, I'm Sammy, and
basically kind of dismissed
me a little bit-- hey,
thanks for letting
me use your car, now
get out of here, kid.
So he drives it out onto
stage, and it kind of
became like a little bit of
an urban legend in St. Louis,
right?
So that was kind of
my first introduction.
And I saw the big
rock show, and I
saw-- I realized that if I
got really good at mixing,
maybe I could get to
that level someday.
So fast forward to, like, 1984.
I kind of got discouraged--
I'll keep this short,
if I can-- and I was going to
just start doing a normal day
gig, because the bands
weren't paying any money,
I was starving to
death, and I went
and saw the Van
Halen "1984" show.
They played two nights.
So at the end of the show,
I was just blown away.
I was, like, I think I want
to do sound engineering again.
So I'm sitting at
this little bar called
Bogart's on the Landing
on the river front,
and I looked to my
left, and David Lee Roth
sits down right
next to me, right?
And I was, like, wow.
So we sit down, and I start
talking to him about martial
arts, and stretching-- I never
even said a word to him about
rock and roll--
BRIAN: Well, you knew he
was David Lee Roth, though.
JERRY: Yeah, I knew who
he was, absolutely, I just
saw him on stage.
I actually wanted to ask him
for a job, but I didn't, right?
So 18 months later, I'm
actually working for him,
because I met a gentleman
that was a drum tech for him.
And he was with the Beach Boys,
and when Dave left Van Halen,
he introduced me
to the Dave camp,
and I ended up 18 months
later working for Dave,
so it's kind of a
weird thing, right.
So this is, like, 1986 or so.
The "Eat 'em and Smile"
tour, and "Skyscraper."
And then in '95, I started
working for Van Halen.
So I'm working for Dave,
I'm working for Van Halen,
neither know that I'm
working for the other,
because I didn't
want to get fired,
so that's kind of how it
kind of just intertwined.
And then, in '95, when I
was working for Van Halen,
we decided to put
Alex on in-ears,
and that's kind of how
Ultimate Ears started.
BRIAN: So I hear the story is
that Alex and Eddie came to you
and said, we're
basically going deaf.
What do we do, right?
JERRY: Yeah, well--
BRIAN: This is what happens.
Right?
JERRY: Well, Alex was going deaf
because he had Eddie's guitar
cabinet blaring behind him,
he had these two big PA
systems behind
him, so he's had--
he was just getting
killed with volume.
And it sounded
really bad out front,
because all this stuff is
going through the drum mics.
So in-ear monitors
was in its infancy,
and people were focusing more on
the transmitters and receivers
than they were the
earphone side of it.
They wanted to save the
rest of Alex's hearing,
so we decided to try to
put him on in-ear monitors.
Well, it didn't go so well,
because even though he
had had some-- he'd
been around loud music--
the guy's got an
amazing ear, and he
can hear tonality
and everything else.
There was two companies back
then that, in the beginning,
had started putting,
basically, either a balanced
armature in a silicone
mold, or, basically,
a Sony diaphragm in a mold, and
called them in-ear monitors.
So we get him a set of each,
and he listens to the first set,
plays about four beats, takes
them out, throws them down,
puts the second set in.
Plays about four
beats, and he goes,
these things sound horrible.
He goes, I suggest we
find something better.
And I said, well, they
don't make anything better.
And he goes, well, maybe
you should figure out
how to make something
better, then.
And he gets up and walks
off to his drum kit,
so that's kind of how I
started down the path.
BRIAN: It all comes back
to Van Halen, every time.
JERRY: Yeah, I didn't
want to build anything.
I never thought about
it, but I was kind of
instructed to do it, and
I wanted to keep my gig,
so I decided I
was going to build
something that sounded better.
BRIAN: So I think the story is
that, there was nothing that
was better, so you had to figure
out how to make something.
So you used parts
from-- well, you
can describe it-- you used
parts from a pacemaker and parts
from a hearing aid, and somehow
jury-rigged this stuff up
to work.
It was somehow better
than everything else
out there, which is amazing.
JERRY: Well, I realized,
by starting to experiment
with the components, that
one component couldn't
do the complete frequency
response from lows to high.
You could have-- with
the balanced armature,
it was kind of a hearing
aid driver, basically,
a hot-rodded
hearing aid speaker.
You could get good lows--
not lows, but low mids, mids,
and highs, but no real sub bass.
And then, with the diaphragm
speaker that's in a Sony bud,
you get nice lows,
but you couldn't
get any top-end extension.
So I realized that, looking
up at the PA system,
it wasn't rocket science.
I was like, well, we've been
putting multiple lows, mids,
and highs, with crossovers,
in big speakers.
Why can't we do it in
a miniature earphone?
So I started just
researching, and trying
to find miniature
components, and landed--
a gentleman named Rick
Cenardo, at a company
called [? Knowles, ?]
became my liaison,
and he was sending me samples.
I would put them
on the analyzer,
with-- it was modeling
clay, and an analyzer mic--
and shoot pink noise
through it, and see
what the frequency response was.
So I found a driver that was
suitable for mids and highs,
but I couldn't
find a driver that
had the capacity,
for live performance,
for low frequency reproduction.
So I get a call from Rick.
He goes, hey, I found this
thing in the armature cemetery.
He goes, it's a
pacemaker speaker.
He goes, what it's for is,
if someone has a pacemaker,
it has to emit 140 dB
tone, or 130 dB tone,
through their chest, to let them
know that they're going to get
zapped, so they might
want to sit down, right?
So I was, like,
cool, send it to me.
So I shoot pink noise through
it, I'd all of a sudden
it's like, wow, this thing
is a perfect bass driver.
So then I made a
little crossover,
and pop them into Alex's ears,
he smiled, and I was like, wow,
you know?
So that's kind of how
all that just-- it
was just trial and error,
and a lucky call from Rick,
and that's kind of how
it all came together.
And that was the first UE 5, the
first two-way in-ear monitor.
BRIAN: So I guess the next
question is, so how do you
go from a guy who has sort
of thrown this together
from the graveyard of hearing
aid parts to someone who
all the rock stars are coming
and begging for products?
So they say that Sebastian Bach
came, begging you with cash,
he said, give me
as many as you can,
and Engelbert Humperdinck, and
everyone's coming and begging.
So what do you do?
You have to mass produce these.
What happens?
JERRY: Well, it
was kind of funny.
Skid Row was opening
for Van Halen,
and they saw Alex was happy.
And they had the other models,
and they weren't happy.
So I built them six
sets of in-ear monitors.
They asked me if
I could do it, I
go, yeah, I'll
build you six sets.
And I'd never sold anything.
It wasn't a company.
And I walk into the
production office,
and the tour manager goes,
well, how much do I owe you?
I was like, well, $500 a pair.
So he hands me
three grand, right?
And I was like, this
is three weeks' work.
This is a lot more profitable
than actually mixing
for a living, so that's when
I decided to do Ultimate Ears.
But what happened was,
Westone was the company
that did the shells for me,
because I had no concept of how
to mold it, but I did
all the audio circuits.
So there's a couple
good guys at Westone
that I became very
good friends with,
Karl and Kris Cartwright,
and so I told them,
I'm going to start a company.
Will you guys be my OEM?
And they're like, yeah,
we'll build them for you.
So I basically became the
design and the marketing side
of Ultimate Ears, and
then they were my OEM.
They would do the
manufacturing for me.
So that's how we kept
up with production.
I had to outsource it, because
I didn't have the capability
to do any of the
molding or anything.
BRIAN: And so, at
some point, then, you
decided to split with Westone,
and start manufacturing
on your own.
So again, when you're
in a situation,
as a small business owner,
where all of a sudden, you--
Where all of a sudden, you
can't interrupt your business,
but you just start doing
things you haven't done before.
So how do you just,
out of nowhere,
learn to manufacture
the shells as well?
Without interrupting
your business?
JERRY: We were having a
kind of a little divorce
situation going on between
Westone and myself,
and the president told me,
we can't really divorce,
because you don't know
how to build the product.
So you're going to just
kind of have to toe the line
and do this.
So I decided to go
to Florida, and learn
how to build hearing aids.
And I went to a place
called Electone.
And I stayed there
for two weeks,
trying to learn how
to build shells,
and to do hearing
aid fabrication.
And realized that
I was not going
to be able to get the
skill set within two weeks
to start my own lab, so
I hired the instructor.
And I said, hey, if
I double your salary,
will you come to Vegas
and start a lab with me?
And he said, yeah, no problem.
So he shows up.
I had bought all this
equipment, and he's,
like, you bought all
the stuff that's wrong.
You know?
So I was, like, great.
And I had a little
light to make shells,
it was about six
inches by six inches,
and he called it the
Barbie tanning bed.
He goes, I can't make your
pieces with Barbie tanning bed.
So we revamped, and we continued
to let Westone manufacture,
and then we basically
developed the process that
now is kind of what
all of the companies
are doing, as far as the
ultraviolet cure shells,
so, we figured it out.
We decided, OK, now
we're ready to go,
so started building
all the stuff in house.
So the first 100 pair I built,
I rebuilt them maybe four times.
And my customers
were really cool,
because I was
telling them, well,
I trying to learn
how to build this.
They would fail, and
they'd send them back,
but within about 90 days
we had the process down,
and everybody supported
us out in the pro market.
So that's how
Ultimate Ears-- that's
how my manufacturing
side got started.
Out of necessity.
BRIAN: So during
this whole process,
you're still mixing for bands.
You were mixing for Kiss,
and for all these bands,
and I've heard some
interesting stories.
One of them that I
read was about how
you had some interesting
shouting matches
with Gene Simmons, where he
thought he was shouting at you,
but it turns out you
may not have been there.
JERRY: Yeah, in Gene's defense,
the equipment back then was not
really good, and maybe I
didn't have the chops, either,
but we had some monumental,
historic squabbles
back and forth, kind of
like a husband and wife.
We were in a truck stop
one night, and I look over,
and there's this cardboard
cut-out, full size,
of "Big Daddy" Don Garlits.
He's holding a Kendall
oil can, right?
I said, I'm going to steal that.
So I stole it.
I took it, I put it on the
bus, and from that point on--
I put a Kiss t-shirt on it, and
then I put a bunch of scruff
on it, because I was so
miserable on that tour
that I wouldn't shave.
So I kind of made
it look like me.
I put a Kiss hat on it.
And we always had this
scrim in front of us.
It was like a black
mesh scrim, but I
had to have a light on my
face, so Gene could see my face
when he was, as you could
say, maybe, talking to me.
So every time I would
get upset with Gene,
I would tell my third
man, give me "Big Daddy."
So what I would do is, I would
take the cardboard cut-out,
and I'd put it behind
the mixing console,
and I'd walk off
and take a breather,
and not be mad anymore.
And when I'd cool
down, I'd come back.
Well, that might be
four or five songs.
And then Gene would
come over, and start
yelling at the
cardboard cut-out.
And everybody on stage knew
about it, but he didn't, right?
So it got to be kind
of a running joke,
and we had to put him up
there more than-- actually, I
think the cardboard cut-out
probably made more money than I
did on that tour after that.
So that's kind of the
"Big Daddy" story.
BRIAN: Cool.
So I want to talk
a bit about JH,
but before that, I want to
talk about how you realized,
OK, well, you're selling
these really high-end units
to rock stars that
cost a lot of money,
they're very highly customized.
At some point, you
realize that everyone's
running around listening
to really bad earphones,
and there's an opportunity
there for consumer, too.
So I want to talk about what
it takes for someone who's
used to making $1,000
units, $2,000 units, what
do you do when you decide,
OK, I want to make things
for a market that can't afford
to spend more than $100,
or $200, and how that happens?
How you become a kind of
split between pro and sort
of the lower end consumer?
JERRY: Obviously, that change
came about with the iPod.
Because before the iPod, people
would buy $60, $100 CD players,
and no one wanted to
spend more than $50
for a set of Sony buds.
2003, I was mixing
the Linkin Park guys,
and the production assistant
walks up and hands me an iPod.
I was like, what is this thing?
So she explains that there's
a bunch of songs on it,
and I put my earpieces
in, and I listen.
I go, it's a pretty good fit.
The earpieces sound
good with the player.
So I quit the tour, came
back, because the lab's going,
so I'm still touring
with bands and stuff,
so I quit the tour to come back
and start, like, a consumer
division.
And it was an
interesting experience,
because these forums had just
started, like Head-Fi and all
of that, and went
out and spoke Apple
at the time, because
they were iPod,
and they gave us some support.
But we actually grew--
I think in three years,
we grew 1,000%, just
off of the consumers.
So I ended up having
to build a lower cost
unit that the
consumers would buy.
And what's kind of crazy
now is, it's shifted.
The consumers are
more interested
in the high-end stuff,
especially Southeast Asian,
people that really
appreciate the audio quality.
In the beginning, we thought
we had to really build
these low cost earpieces,
and now, today, everybody's
used to buying more top shelf
stuff than the more reasonably
priced stuff.
BRIAN: And is the
technology moving down
from the really high-end?
Is it getting cheaper
to manufacture,
so you can put really
high-end equipment?
Or did the cost pretty
much stay the same?
JERRY: No, the costs
are staying the same,
because the companies
that build the components,
they know they have a monopoly.
Even though I design them and
I have them build to my specs,
they still know they're
the only game in town.
There's only a
couple-- two companies
that build the components.
They've kept the cost
of the components high,
so it's really kind of hard
to get anything really,
really cheap.
I don't think you'll
ever see a $100 multi
driver earpiece,
until they decide
they want to increase volume,
versus the profit margin.
BRIAN: And so that was
sort of the next question.
So how is it that the two
companies that you founded,
JH and Ultimate Ears,
are the companies
that everyone goes to?
Why is nobody else able
to break into this market?
Is it because of you?
Because the
components are just--
you've locked up the market,
or-- why can no one else
compete here?
JERRY: Well, I'd like to say it
was me, but-- but no, it's not.
Ultimate Ears is just a brand
that's been around since 1995,
so people know the brand.
All of the components that
I use inside my earphones
are built to my
specs, so they're not
off the shelf components.
They may have the same
can sizes-- what anybody
can buy and put into a
shell-- but they're all
to my spec, my impedance curves.
So I think that Ultimate
Ears, when I was there,
and Jerry Harvey Audio
now, I think it's
more of the audio signature
and performance that
keeps people coming back to us.
It's really easy now to
learn how to build a mold
and put a bunch of
components in it, but it's
getting those components
tuned, and in phase,
and to play correctly
with each other,
that actually-- the
end result is better
if you know what you're doing.
I'm not saying that I'm the
only person who knows that,
but I think the end user,
when they compare A,
B, C, and D, when they listen,
they can actually hear,
kind of, the audio
signature that I think
is pleasing to most people.
BRIAN: So let's then talk
about JH Audio, then.
So you sell Ultimate
Ears, and you
decide to start out
on your own again.
And so, what's
different this time?
You're again starting
out from zero,
and you have this
big user base, and--
JERRY: Look, I didn't
sell Ultimate Ears.
I kind of was on the
backside of that.
Watch venture capital,
and I'll leave it at that.
So we started Jerry
Harvey Audio, JH Audio,
and I had a little
bit of a break period,
because I had a non-compete.
But I wasn't done
designing the earphones.
I had designs I'd been working
on for that two-year period
that I wanted to get out
into the marketplace.
So for me, JH Audio is just a
continuation of Ultimate Ears,
and just gives me
a platform to keep
designing products and trying
to push the technology forward.
BRIAN: And so what are
you doing differently now?
You've been in this
business for a long time,
and so you're releasing
things like Roxanne,
which no one's ever seen before.
So what's everyone else doing?
Are they seeing this,
and-- what's happening?
JERRY: I'm not sure what
the competition's doing,
but I just keep finding new
ways to improve the technology.
Like things that
are very obvious,
that I overlooked for 15 years.
Time and phase.
You have to make sure that
everything's in time and phase
in order to have a
proper phase curve.
When I was working
on the Roxanne,
I discovered that if
I could put everything
in time, the low,
mid, and highs,
within a hundredth
of a millisecond,
that I had a perfectly
flat phase response.
Which is what gives
you the imaging.
Especially in the center image,
where there's no interaction.
Any phase cancellation's
going to take place
where the center image works.
So I think the biggest
thing-- there's
two things that I believe
that have set Jerry Harvey
Audio apart from everyone else.
Time phase-- making
sure everything's
in correct time and
phase-- and then
figuring out how to get
the top-end extension out
of a balanced armature earpiece.
It's really easy
to get lows, mids.
Getting any top-end
extension above 10 k
is the difficult part, because
of how balanced armatures work.
BRIAN: All right, so that's
a good lead in, I guess,
for the next set of questions.
I'm curious about your thoughts
on modern audio engineering.
Lots of people here listen
to Spotify, or Google,
Google Music, things like this.
And these are all compressed.
So what does this do for
you, as a designer, when
you have to make products
that people are using
to listen to compressed-- that
may be very different from what
the pros are listening to.
JERRY: I would never design
a product that sounded good
with low quality audio.
So my basic concept for
designing an audio product
is to make it
straight-through plumbing.
That you should get out
of it exactly what you
put into it, with varying
degrees of bass response,
because bass is like spice--
some people like bland food,
some people like spicy food.
So no one ever
tells me, you know,
I really don't want-- I don't
want an accurate frequency
response, but they
always ask me how much
bass does an
earpiece have in it.
So my concept is
to make an earpiece
that, every time you make
the audio signal better
that the ear piece
reproduces, will ramp up
with a higher
quality audio signal.
Nowadays you have these
high resolution players,
like the Astell Kern players
that are doing 192 files,
they're doing DSD with dual
DACs and killer headphone amps,
so those players really shine
with a good set of headphones,
or a good set of earpieces.
And I will say that,
when you do have
a really good set of
headphones, or earphones,
when you play a low res file,
you hear a low res file.
So I would never design anything
to try to polish that up.
BRIAN: It sort of reminds
me when CDs first came out,
when they said there was
a warning on the CD that
says, warning-- this
may reveal weaknesses
in the original recording.
Because this is digital, and
it was recorded really poorly
10 years ago.
JERRY: I think that that's
the beauty of the recordings,
though.
Some of those old
analog recordings,
even when you hear
them remastered,
they still sound--
they sound analog.
And they sound
amazing, and I think
listening to an old recording
that's been remastered
is still pretty cool.
Listen to some of the
songs in the '60s.
They had such good melodies,
and such good hooks.
You were listening to
it on an AM radio that
had limited frequency response,
but the song still rocked.
Either it was a good
song, or it wasn't.
I appreciate the old
recordings, and I
think that hearing it the
way it was recorded back
then, but in high
res, is really cool.
BRIAN: So I guess
the last one is,
so JH traditionally is
making professional IEMs.
But the consumer
market is enormous.
So how do you market
into that market?
How do you break into that?
How do you convince people who
think that the iPod earphones
that they get-- how
do you convince people
there's something better?
JERRY: Well, I think, because of
Google, and because of the way
that the world works now,
especially the internet,
anybody that just puts
in "a better headphone"
is going to end up at
one of the chat rooms,
the head-fi dot-- I
don't know-- dot org,
or something like that.
So I think that people
do their research,
and by doing their research,
they kind of stumble upon me.
Or Ultimate Ears, or
one of our companies.
BRIAN: And so
also, you mentioned
that all the high-end
products that JH makes
are all custom fit, except
for the Roxanne, which
you mentioned has a
universal fit as well.
So is the movement for
consumer towards universal fit,
I assume, because it
is easier to sell?
Right?
JERRY: People want
instant gratification,
but I think they also want
higher quality audio out
of the one size fits all.
The trend in Southeast
Asia, which hasn't quite
hit America yet, is that,
there's a few companies that
were building high-end,
one size fits all.
They were also custom companies.
So the audio quality
was increasing.
It wasn't the $200 to
$300 mass produced out
of China earphones.
They're selling
things for-- Shure
just put out a new product, the
846, which is a good product,
for $1,200.
And a company called
FitEar, a Japanese company,
has a product that's $1,500.
That's one size fits all--
it's not even custom.
So when I saw that
trend, for me,
I always want to one-up
everyone in the marketplace,
so I took my new
product, Roxanne,
and just made a
universal fit out of it,
so I could kind of, like, one-up
everyone, and it's amazing.
It's an expensive product,
but we can't build it
fast enough in the
one size fits all.
I think that anybody
that appreciates audio,
and if they get
what they pay for,
if they want a good
product, it's available now.
Before, that option
wasn't available.
BRIAN: And are you selling
the universal fits in stores,
or are they still
only sold directly?
JERRY: The universal fits are
only sold through our dealers.
So Julie is one of our
dealers in New York.
She sells them.
And then we have dealers
all across the country.
We'll have, I think,
Earphone Solutions.
There's a couple other
companies out there
that'll start selling
them here pretty soon.
So those aren't sold
direct at the present time.
They're all sold
through our dealers,
and they'll be listed
on the website shortly.
We just launched it.
BRIAN: Does anyone
have any questions?
About audio engineering, about
rock stars, about anything?
So please come to the
mic if you want to talk.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for coming today.
I have a set of
Triple Fi 10's there.
JERRY: Oh, cool.
AUDIENCE: But I was just curious
about the trend that music
is taking now, with, I guess,
recorded music becoming
more compressed in general?
And how you're taking
that into account
with how you design
headphones, where you have
an even response in your
earpieces, but the music
itself may not be
up to par for that--
for what people are
starting to listen to.
So I was just curious
how you're handling that.
JERRY: Well, I'll touch on it.
I don't change the way I build
a product, or tune a product,
for the lower compressed files.
But I do think that
what's happening
is that people are becoming more
aware of the high resolution
files out on the internet.
Like you have hdtracks.net.
You have about a half
dozen websites out
there that you can actually
download pretty much any album
that you've ever loved in 192,
that's been remastered-- or not
remastered, but at least 96 k.
So I think the
trend-- obviously,
anybody that's listening
to very compressed music
is not an audiophile.
They probably will be OK with
a normal set of headphones.
AUDIENCE: My question is
more how the bands themselves
are recording [INAUDIBLE].
JERRY: Yeah, it's kind of crazy.
You listen to some of these
records that are mastered,
they're mastered so
they sound really loud.
That's just a preference of
whoever the mix engineer is.
Whoever's doing the mastering.
But I hope that that trend
of making things compressed
and sounding really kind of
loud, kind of like the-- well,
I won't mention any bands-- that
that trend actually reverses,
and people are trying to
get a more analog sound out
of it, instead that
highly compressed sound.
I'm not recording engineer,
I'm a live sound engineer,
so I'm not really in tune
with the recording process
of what they're doing in
the studios these days.
BRIAN: That's actually an
interesting follow up I had.
So you're mixing what the
band is hearing on stage,
and there's a guy in
the audience who's
mixing what the
audience is hearing.
So what are the differences?
What are the
differences in how you
mix for the band versus how
they mix for the audience?
JERRY: Well, I have to
make the band happy.
So it's kind of like Burger
King "have it your way."
It's like a service industry.
There's a lot of people I
work for that I would never
get that sound on my
own that they like
to listen to while
they're performing.
So I basically interact with
the band, and I please the band.
And the front house engineer has
to please the guitar player's
girlfriend, he has to
please the manager,
so it's a totally different
concept out front.
You're judged by a
lot of other people,
and reviews in the
newspaper, and-- for me, I
get an instant
review from the band.
Either they like
it or they don't.
So it's kind of less pressure
than being the guy out front
that's totally under
the microscope.
BRIAN: Well, is it
common for the bands
to want to listen, though, to
what the audience is hearing,
so they know what
they're experiencing?
JERRY: Well, it's really funny.
What they do-- they
always get a board tape
at the end of the night.
Now they have,
basically, pro tools,
so they can kind
of do a quick mix.
But the funny thing is, is
now that-- the last Van Halen
tour I did, Alex would come in
with a cellphone and a YouTube
clip, and go, listen to
what this sounds like.
And we're, like,
well, we don't even
know what part of the building
that guy was sitting in, right?
So some people want to
listen to the YouTube stuff,
and try to make it sound-- like,
Alex wants it to sound good,
and translate to that AM
radio-sounding cellphone.
And then other bands who just
want to hear a full mix down
of multi track that's
gone down to a CD
at the end of the night, so
they can review if they're
performing right, or
what it sounds like.
But the only thing
that you hear if you're
a musician, unless you're
going out in front of the PA,
all you're hearing is a bunch
of slap off the back wall,
and low-end coming off
the PA, so you really
have no idea what it sounds
like in the front of the house.
You just have to trust
the people that are out
in front, that are your
people, to give you
a straight story of what
it sounds like, right?
BRIAN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming
in and talking to us.
I'm sure there's a lot
of engineers in the room.
I was wondering if you
could talk through some
of the technical
considerations you make,
in terms of designing
your headphones?
So I'm thinking about how
you choose your crossovers?
Is a flat frequency
response the ideal response?
How you deal with phase issues,
if you have two bass drivers,
for example?
So if you could just talk
through those a little bit.
JERRY: Sure.
First of all, I would
never tune anything flat.
I think flat's boring.
Kick drums shouldn't sound
like a baseball hitting a mitt,
right?
But that's my
personal preference,
so I always tune things a
little bit more bottom end.
But as far as-- I'll just
speak to the phase first.
When you're using multi
driver components,
they all have different
time signatures.
Just like a PA system.
The low frequencies
are longer sound waves,
and high frequencies
are much shorter.
So in a PA system, if you
look at it without any time
correction, the highs
are going to be early,
the mids are going to
be a little bit later,
and the lows are going
to be really slow.
So what you do, and nowadays
you don't have to do it,
but what the DSP's done
is they've basically
delayed the mids,
delayed the highs,
so everything arrives
at the same time, right?
And then you put it
in time with the sub.
So that's kind of what
I've done in the earpiece,
but I've done a
physical wave guide.
So I discovered that-- we've
got better software now,
because of the power of the PC.
I can test phase
curves, and I can
get within hundredth of a
millisecond on the impulse
time of those little
miniature drivers.
So I found that
as soon as I went
within a hundredth
of a millisecond,
that the crossover points
became perfect, where I actually
had to change my
crossover shapes
because they became so efficient
at the crossover points,
and that the phase
response basically became,
not perfectly flat, but no more
than 10 degrees off of zero,
which is unheard of
in an in-ear monitor,
because they're pretty
much-- up until that point,
were all out of phase.
Either at the crossover point,
or some of the old drivers
were just out of phase across
the bandwidth just internally,
right?
So that's the phase side of it.
The other big obstacle,
as I mentioned earlier,
is high frequency response.
So when I design-- like
this new piece, the Roxanne.
The first in-ear
monitor I designed?
The high frequency
extension rolled off at 8 k,
and there was no way that
we could get it to go out
any further, and
that's because the way
that a balanced armature
impedance curve works.
So what happens is, as
it goes up in frequency,
the impedance rises.
So you may have
10 ohms in a 1 k,
and you'll have
100 ohms at 20 k.
So what happens is,
the headphone amp
doesn't see a load, and
the high end roll off
is inverse to the rise
in the impedance curve.
So it looks like a hockey stick,
and it does the same thing.
What I found is,
that if I can change
the shape of the
impedance curve,
that I can actually get more
high frequency extension.
The reason I use four
drivers on the Roxanne
is because I could
actually tune those coils.
If you do DC, from
10 Hertz to 20 k,
the thing will measure 1/2 ohm.
But as soon as you
high pass it out to 4k,
it measures 20 ohms, right?
Right there.
So what I ended up doing was,
by having four components,
I could wire them
all in parallel,
high pass them, and have
the headphone amp see a load
at 20 k, which is
why the Roxanne is
the first earpiece I've ever
got that will go out past 20 k
before, and still have
usable information.
Not down 12 or 14 dB,
or something like that.
So that's the biggest time.
And then, as far as
the audio response,
I never tune anything flat.
I tune it accurate.
So if you were to see
it on an FFT analyzer,
you would get out of it
exactly what you put into it.
I kind of shape the
top end roll off
where I think it's pleasing.
And then I set
the bass response.
Like the new piece.
Every day I answer
the question, how much
base does a
particular model have?
So with the new
piece I designed,
I put attenuators
on the bass driver,
so you can set it
zero to plus 15.
So you can basically set
the bass where you like it,
so it kind of preempted
the conversation there.
So did that answer
any of your questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JERRY: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm actually a live
engineer, so I've
got a question sort of from
that side of the fence.
JERRY: OK.
AUDIENCE: In terms of modern
front of house systems,
and even dynamic driver
monitor systems these days,
DSP, like you sort of mentioned,
is a really big thing.
So do you see that, sort of,
coming to the in-ear market?
In terms of things
like customizability?
So the bass response, the
high response, whatever,
change against, sort
of, that person's taste?
Even in the consumer
market, where
you don't have a monitor guide
to sort of boost your top end,
or whatever?
JERRY: I see that coming
in the near future.
I built a three-way
amplifier a couple years ago,
called the 3A, so it didn't give
the user the interface that I
wanted it to, because it
was three amps in there.
But I do believe that DSP,
equalization, and control
of the circuit, for an
end user, is really close.
I think the bottom end
control on the Roxanne
is just the starting point.
If you look at that
earpiece, I actually
took the passive
crossover circuit--
there's four pins
at the earpiece,
so you have ground,
low, mid, and high.
So my idea is that
you could actually
put an attenuator on any band,
and just do a broad low, mid,
and high adjustment,
if you liked.
I'm kind of doing an open market
to the cable manufacturers'
aftermarket.
And also, I think
that the only way
that we're going to get any
more out of an in-ear monitor
with the current technology
is going to be control-based.
So that's been on my road
map for quite a while.
But what I think that
really needs to happen
is, I think that giving the
end user the control over being
able to set the shape, the
equalization, to kind of mess
around with the crossover--
that's what I would like.
So to some people, that may
be above their skill set.
It might need to be
a little simpler.
But I think, at
the end of the day,
that that's not too far off.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
That's all.
BRIAN: Is that control the
kind of thing you think
will move into
your other models?
So you think that other,
besides the Roxanne,
will let you adjust
the bass, and so on?
JERRY: Yeah.
I think that that's going
to be an ongoing trend.
And just giving the
end user more control
over the audio signature.
BRIAN: I guess it's interesting,
also, for the consumer market.
Some people like
listening to rap,
some people listen to rock, and
they have different opinions
of how much bass
there should be,
and how much treble
there should be.
JERRY: That's why I kind of
set the Roxanne that way.
So if you want heavy bass,
it'll shake your fillings out.
If you want flat, it's flat.
BRIAN: Who needs fillings?
JERRY: Yeah.
Who needs fillings?
BRIAN: Any other questions?
Cool.
JERRY: Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE] Appreciate
your coming.
Thank you.
Thanks for coming.